翻訳: Mami Iwamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
「全ての子供はアーティストだ」
自身 偉大なアーティストだった
パブロ・ピカソが言っています
彼はこう続けました
「問題は 大人になってからも
アーティストでいられるかどうかだ」
皆さんはたぶん小さな頃
たくさん絵を描いたと思います
たくさん物を作ったと思います
今日 スケッチブック持ってこられてる方
いらっしゃいますか？
結構いらっしゃいますね 良かった
皆さん きっと心の中で
物を作りたいという欲求
絵を描きたいという欲求
「創造欲求」と呼んでいますが
創造欲求を持っていると思います
そんな僕たちも 創造欲求を持っています
まず僕たちの作品を是非
ご覧になってください
（音楽）
[(英語)スイート ホーム
金澤麻由子 井村政孝 金谷一郎]
[ロウソクに火を灯してください]
[そうすれば絵の中に入れます]
[スイート ホーム]
[協力 清水 山本 山本 伊藤]
（音楽終わり）
今見ていただいたのは
ここ神戸出身のアーティスト
金澤麻由子と 井村政孝と
そして僕とで作らせて頂いて
いくつかの美術館で
何度も展示をさせていただいた作品
『SWEET HOME』です
この作品 絵を見ている人が
ろうそくに火を灯すと
いつのまにか
絵の中に入ってしまいます
絵の中で 大きなケーキを
アルパカ君が持ってきてくれます
「お誕生日おめでとう」といって
ハグをしてくれます
参加者は この絵を見ている人は
本当にハグされた気持ちになります
このように対話を楽しむ作品
これを「インタラクティブアート作品」
という風に呼びます
「インタラクティブアート作品」は
コンピューターによって動いています
ちょうど18世紀のアーティストが
当時最先端の技術であった
チューブ入り絵具を使いこなしていたように
現代のアーティストは
コンピュータを使うこともあります
今日皆さんと共有したいアイデアは
コンピュータテクノロジーと
アート作品の関係です
実はこの作品を
主導的に製作した金澤麻由子さんは
コンピュータサイエンティスト
ではありません
ではどうしてこのような作品が
可能になったのでしょうか？
その前に アートとテクノロジーの関係を
少しおさらいしておきたいと思います
我々は「アート」それから「テクノロジー」
という言葉をよく使います
あるいは「美術」と「技術」という風に
呼ぶかもしれません
「アート」と「テクノロジー」は
対立するものでしょうか？
ここで語源を振り返ってみたいと思います
アートの語源は
ラテン語の「アルス」
テクノロジーの語源はギリシャ語の
「テクネ」だという風に考えられています
そして ラテン語の「アルス」と
ギリシャ語の「テクネ」
実は同じ意味だったんです
全く同じ意味だったんです
どんな意味か？
人が物を作る事
あるいは人が作った物
これをラテン語では「アルス」と呼び
ギリシャ語では「テクネ」 と呼んでいました
つまり「アート」と「テクノロジー」は
もともと同じ意味だったんです
18世紀の産業革命が 美術としてのアート
「ファインアート」と
「技術としてのテクノロジー」を
分離してしまいました
でも「アート」と「テクノロジー」は
同じものだったんです
少し興味深い例を見てみたいと思います
先ほど 現代のアーティストにとって
コンピュータは絵具だという風に
申し上げました
1977年 世界で最初の
パーソナルコンピュータが生まれました
写真はそのApple Ⅱとその設計者
スティーブ・ウォズニアック
通称スティーブ・ウォズです
Apple Ⅱは蓋をあけて
中身をいじることができました
実際 ウォズの後ろで
配線をいじっている人がいます
誰だと思います？
スティーブ・ジョブズでした
ご本人ですよ
彼の左腕を見てください
Apple Watchをしています
（笑）
僕とお揃い
スティーブ・ジョブズは
コンピュータサイエンティストとして
知られているわけではありません
そんな彼でも中身をいじれたコンピュータ
それがApple Ⅱの時代のコンピュータと
いう風に言えるかもしれません
現代のコンピュータはどうでしょう？
例えば このRaspberry Pi 2
蓋がないので
もちろん中身をいじることはできます
でも本当にいじれるでしょうか？
Apple Ⅱに比べたらとても複雑
とても中身をいじれるような
コンピュータではありません
ウォズはきっと
中をいじったかもしれませんが
スティーブ・ジョブズなら
MacやiPhoneのように
金属製のケースに収めてしまうと思います
アーティストにとって
どちらが好ましいんでしょうか？
ウォズのように
自由に扱えるようにしたいのか？
ジョブズのように
シンプルなコンピュータが欲しいのか？
我々はきっと そのどこかで
バランスを取らないといけないんです
大正11年 1922年
ここ神戸に上陸した
アルベルト・アインシュタインは
こういう風に言っています
「物事は全て 可能な限り
シンプルでなければならない
ただし シンプルすぎてはいけない」
僕たちもその原則に従いたいと思います
コンピュータ
可能な限りシンプルだけれども
シンプル過ぎないコンピュータが必要です
作りました
Pineapple Ⅱという名前です
（笑）
良い名前でしょ？
Appleが訴えないか
今 ドキドキしています
（笑）
このコンピュータは自然現象を
コンピュータの言葉へと変えていきます
少しデモンストレーションをしてみます
ここに今 Pineapple Ⅱがあります
机と手の距離を見ておいて下さいね
え 画面が
—あ ごめんなさい—
これ音も出るんですよ
—音も出しますねー
（音）
手を近づけていくと
こんな風に
（音がだんだんと変わる）
今 手と机の距離
こういう自然現象を
コンピューターの言葉に置き換えてみました
別の例をお見せします
次は 曲げる角度
（音）
これ 見えますか？
曲げる角度です
このリボンを曲げていきます
曲げると音が低くなりました
色も変わりました
伸ばしました
これは こういう風に
手袋にくっつけて
指を曲げたりすると
こんな風に手の形をコンピュータに
伝えることもできるようになります
それから もう1つ
僕のお気に入りをお見せしたいと思います
これは押す場所によって
圧力によって 音が変わってきます
今 ここを押さえていますが
真ん中あたりを押さえるとこんな感じ
これ 音楽できそうですね
こんな感じです
押さえる場所によって音が変わってきます
見えますか？ 皆さん
二つ押すとこんな感じですね
じゃあデモはこのぐらいにしておきます
（音終わり）
はい
このPineapple Ⅱが
どういう風に動いていたのか
ご紹介したいと思います
自然現象を MacやiPhoneのような
コンピュータは
直接理解することはできません
そこでこの間にPineapple Ⅱという
コンピュータを挟むことになります
センサーが自然現象を
電気信号に置き換えます
その電気信号をPineapple Ⅱは
コンピュータが理解できる言葉へと
置き換えます
どんな言葉でしょうか？
コンピュータの世界には
世界で使われている
英語のような言葉があります
そういった言葉に
置き換えることによって
どんなコンピュータを持ってきても使える
とてもシンプルな だけどシンプルすぎない
コンピュータの構成になりました
実はこのPineapple Ⅱ
設計をすべて公開しています
もしシンプルすぎると思ったら
皆さん自身で作り変える事もできます
実際にこのコンピュータを使って
学生が作品を作りました
それをまず見ていただきたいと思います
京都嵯峨芸術大学の
奥村拓弥君という学生の作品です
（音楽）
[(英語) 奥村拓弥]
[音楽 From the Dust]
（音楽終わり）
奥村拓弥君はこの作品を
だいたい3ヶ月くらいで作りました
そのうち2ヶ月ぐらいは
どうやって綺麗なスモークを出すか？
というところで
試行錯誤してくれました
なぜコンピューターがシンプルでなくては
いけないのでしょうか？
なぜチューブ入り絵具のように
簡単に使えないといけないのでしょうか？
この写真は 映画マトリックスを撮影した
監督 ウォシャウスキーズです
ウォシャウスキーズと一緒に
コンビを組んだ
映画プロデューサー ジョエル・シルバーは
ウォシャウスキーズを
非常に褒めていまして
こういう言葉を言っています
「自分が何を撮りたいかを知っている
映画監督は滅多にいない」
僕たちは 多分 皆さんも
ウォシャウスキーズのような
天才ではありません
自分が何を作りたいか
作ってみないとわからないんです
作って壊して 作って壊して
ある時作って
「これはちょっと
作りたいものちゃうな」とか
「あっ これ作りたかったんや」
とか
色んな事を
何度も何度も繰り返して
ようやく自分たちの創造欲求を
初めて満たす事が出来るんです
最後にもう一つ 僕たちの作品を
見てもらいたいと思います
同じく 金沢麻由子 井村政孝
そして僕が作った作品で
ここ神戸で２年に１度開かれる
アートの祭典「神戸ビエンナーレ」で
賞をいただいた作品です
映像の中で小さな子供が出てきます
子供がやはり絵の中に入っていくんですが
絵の中でジャンプをすると
マントヒヒがおしっこをかけにきます
ご覧になってください
（音楽）
[ポリフォニック・ジャンプ
金澤、井村、金谷]
[アートの舞台裏を支えるテクノロジー]
[リアリティ追求のための巨大サイズの油彩]
[光補正のために３Dキャンバスを設置]
[ジャンプを感知する動作感知器]
[アニメーションプログラムの生成]
[手描きによるアニメーション]
[テクノロジーとアートの融合]
[ジャンプ！]
[ポリフォニック・ジャンプ]
[音楽制作 A.Himitsu]
（音楽終わり）
皆さんには スケッチブックに絵を描くように
インターラクティブアート作品にも
取り組んでもらえたらと思っています
その第一歩はとても簡単なことです
「アート」と「テクノロジー」
それは手を使って物を作るという意味でした
パブロ・ピカソはこうも言っています
「良いアーティストはマネをする」
「偉大なアーティストは自分のものにする」
皆さんも自分の手を動かして
物を作ってもらいたいと思います
方法はPineapple Ⅱ
だけではありません
色んな方法があります
絵を描くことから始めても
粘土をこねることから始めても
どんな方法でも結構です
どうか手を 動かしてください
ありがとうございます
（拍手）